Basketball Hall of Famer thrilled to
have back here on the show Kevin McHale
how are you Kevin
yes good to have you here I'll give you
the floor on LeBron James there's so
much conversation about him and magic
and Jordan and the cross of generations
here placed in perspective for me what
you're seeing at LeBron Kevin most of us
come with the guys it is a fantastic
unbelievably gifted basketball player
he's got the vision he sees the entire
floor it's got a really really high
basketball IQ the shots been improving
ever since he got nothing but his
ability to help the team win has been
there since he stepped on the floor he
can rebound the ball he can defend it
but think about some blocks from behind
that he some things for other guys down
and blocking shots he just is a he's a
kind of a hybrid of a lot of different
players but LeBron unique unto himself
so he has got something magic and
Larry's just sighs really look over at
the floor you got just the ability to
put the ball on the floor and attack the
rim like a Michael Jordan did Michael
was younger just shy like as I said and
just been improving he's been playing
that little fade away one leg hurt he's
got were gone right now it's ridiculous
especially against Iran right every time
I shoot sound like that can't go in but
it goes in and you know they think the
guys is every once in a while they're
there their generational type players
but he's been that since he got in and
the fact that he's 33 and still doing it
and really in some ways she's becoming
more efficient at his game is really an
amazing feat baby seems like one of them
madam tell you something well comes
along you know that Michael Jordan
learned burned that's Johnson changes
the NBA route in the late seventies
Michigan State Indiana State taken to
the NBA changing the game forever really
and and LeBrons right in there with
those guys once in a generation type
player so what what do you think it is
about somebody that can take the beating
and perform as well as he seems to be
performing at his highest level at age
33 I mean what was it like for you
as you were playing at that age or Larry
when you were right I mean everything is
relative I mean we had them you know for
us in the Celtics and most games you
have a six seven eight year run and you
know that's kind of come to them you
know cream had a different run ds-11
what's up they'll watch across Georgia
bar when the best players ever been here
long run you had a six seven eight year
run with the Lakers but that did you
know there are very few teams that have
these long long run everybody gets beat
up so by the time we were 33 we had been
beaten up as surgeries had just your
body I just wasn't able to respond you
can still go out and you can still go on
score you could go on quick numbers up
on the board but you weren't able to
dominate the game he's still able to
pass the ball attack if I forget he
hasn't had any major injuries thank
goodness and so he just kind of a freak
of nature that way I think even even by
the time Michael was in his mid-teens
game her change still efficient but more
of a bullet more of a post-up guy
fadeaway yeah Michaels game had changed
as time went on and LeBron is pretty
amazing just because of the easy health
so it's so hard to say the difference
because if I had to had had I not had
injuries I don't think I think playing
at 73 would have been a lot easier
it was the injury that that just just
you know in a calf half of here coming
on rehabbing trying to play it you know
those things just beat you down as a
player I'm so happy to see that LeBron
hasn't had that it's still able to play
Kevin McHale here on the Rich Eisen show
and you are the perfect guest to ask
this question to about Brad Stevens
Kevin since you've seen obviously so
much of this game as a player and a
coach and a grocery shopper how much
because we're hearing tons of credit for
Brad Stevens about the the plays that
he's drawing up and Terry Rozier playing
and Tatum playing to these to this level
that we've seen in the playoffs how much
credit do you think he deserves for this
no credit I just think that you know
every team that has success
so let's let's start at the top with my
good buddy Danny age he went on then and
Danny loves getting long athlete Danny
loves getting scrappy guys with high
basketball IQ he gets a lot of guys I
play the way she did and um you know
he's got a lot of basketball players
there but they think that that Brad guys
is he's able to put people in positions
to succeed and he really he lets his
basketball players play basketball but
you look at a guy like a Chevy or jelly
okay he played a lot against Milosh
shimmy on to the second round pick from
SFU but you might think that you never
saw show me old jelly do throw the ball
the other team you never see em being
tired of all attitude those guys he had
to the role player doing what they do he
lets his basketball player look if
you're a basketball player you have to
drive to the hole you're good to have
some turnovers you're gonna have some
you're gonna have some issues because
that's just that's the nature of the
game no one plays a perfect game look at
Brad what he does with all his role
players how he puts them in positions
they shoot the open shot they don't turn
the ball over they don't make mistakes
he doesn't put them in positions and say
okay hey you know Aron Baynes I want you
to do a dribble handoff attack the
basket if they come throw it to the
quote you know Aron Baynes didn't make
turnovers excuse me left and right
he puts those positions so what he does
is two things that's amazing that he's
out of Bounce stuff is really great he
does two things he allows his role
players to do exactly what they do well
they always help the team they never
hurt the team keep T and then he allows
his basketball player it's gone make
basketball plays put some in position to
make basketball players like I said it's
simple
Tatum's on the right wing want to shoot
a three they close out hard he drives he
comes there draws two players
throws it on to the left wing the left
wing guys they rotate up till you know
Jalen Brown he throws it down the row
here in the corner and we're sure gets a
wide open left corner three all because
of Tatum's ability to drive the ball
drop people in there he puts those
basketball players to draw and kick
position all the times it's a great job
el Horford got a really really high
basketball IQ a lot more tatum along
with
larger aranjuez mark ronald Marcus
Morris he has a lot of high IQ players
but he puts in positions to succeed and
someone was out of bounds players that
Audubon plays excuse me last game so
genius but throw the throw in from Tatum
to brown on the left side of the court
was an amazing drama play then all of a
sudden he has to call a timeout on the
right side late in the game where Al
Horford got that layup
he's pinched down there they took a time
on the balls in the free throw line
there's not a lot of room he drives up a
winner just over the top - Al Horford
and so you got to give Brad Stevens a
ton of credit but he puts guys in
position to succeed and and that's what
you're trying to do is this is the coach
just you know make sure make sure
players better by allowing them to do
what they do well Kevin McHale a couple
more minutes with him here as he calls
in from Philadelphia prior to Game four
between the Celtics and the Sixers on
TNT tonight right here on the Rich Eisen
show your best guess Kevin what a
conversation between Brad Stevens in Red
Auerbach would sound like such a good
great the basketball Chuck regret like
playing chess is like basketball there's
only two things what I'd like to do and
Gregor was just such a basketball junkie
he would love Fred I mean he would sit
there and talk ball with them you know
Brad would you ask Brad why did you do
this he actually gives you an you know
excited I talk basketball with Brad you
know quite a bit her I get a chance to
if Danny's there you know Brad will say
well I was thinking this I was thinking
that and that's what red loves red bows
thinking man's basketball like Joey you
just didn't do this out of happenstance
you did this because you know I saw them
fronting I saw them switching so I made
this adjustment and so redwood loves
that because red loved thinking man's
basketball and yeah red did very much
like Danny did he got a bunch of players
at Hyatt and had high basketball IQ
that's what red like that's it Danny
likes to read and Brad would it would
have a great relationship because red
loves to talk basketball he was just a
fun guys going to the office all the
time to just sit in the chair
all dreadful when he started what he did
were young and he was just it was
fascinating to me just a very
interesting guy and I think he and Brad
would get along wonderfully enjoy and
read read loved guys I think I could see
the game and think the game and you
don't play the game the way they're
playing it so barring anything
unforeseen it looks like we're gonna get
the Eastern Conference Finals that we
expected prior to the season between the
Celtics and and the Cavs but obviously
completely different circumstances what
what do you think that looks like when
it happens Kevin well you know I think
the one thing that that possum can do
it's just like when you watch and I
typically with the heat versus silly you
know look at Belinelli making threes
Illya Sullivan is Dario charged you know
I'm feeling on the perimeter all those
guys were freewheeling and playing
against a very good Miami Heat defensive
team Boston comes in with a whole nother
level of pressure they're up to get
India they're turning your algis on all
these shots are contested Oliver says
all these openings aren't there what
Boston can do this Cleveland they can
put a bunch of different players on
LeBron to make LeBron really work she's
not going to stop LeBron but can you
make it work can you make a couple of
those assists that he's getting we've
seen the whole floor can you turn those
into turnovers by a lot of pressure on
him you know can you just make a couple
of easy shot that he's pacing
he makes us a little bit harder and can
you push up on on the JR Smith can you
push up on the Concord was could you
push up on the kloves can you push up on
all these guys make them put the ball on
the floor and make them make plays and
if you see right now the sultan's are
making Belinelli puts the ball on the
floor they're making JJ Redick futbolme
explore you lose silver put the ball in
for charge you know Robert Covington
they make you uncomfortable the Celtics
make you very uncomfortable now you can
only make with rods so uncomfortable
because he's so good but can you can you
add that little bit of pressure with a
ton of athletes I don't know how to play
can you can you turn those games you
know three four extra possessions go
your way throughout the course of a game
is is huge
taking away two points and adding two
points to your team can they get some
run outs on the defensive end with
steals and stuff so it will be really
really interesting I've often said over
the last six seven years I never ever go
against LeBron James unless they were
playing Golden State then I think okay I
pick Golden State over them but you know
LeBron is so unique it's hard to pick
him over hard to pick any team over his
team's but Boston's uniquely qualified
with all the athletes and all the
toughness they have to put really press
those guys and make it real I tell you
what I I it's going to be really
interesting to see if they can maintain
this type of defense intensity we should
have all yours I assume they will and
then you know you've got big Al Horford
making plays in the middle how and how
they're gonna have are they gonna match
up with him is Tristan Thompson would be
able to sail with him on the perimeter
of ogy I got him passing the kicking and
you know driving and took notes so it's
it's gonna it's gonna be fun I mean it's
going to be really really an interesting
series and you know things change
quickly like I said you know one thought
the Fillies offense would look the way
it did right now when they were playing
Miami the anybody thinks that no all of
a sudden no so pressure is a unique
thing pressure when you're able to press
people up press up on people excuse me
and attack them that pressure builds
drop the gate the four minutes is 48 if
you're not able if you don't have enough
athletes that are able to release that
pressure beat them on one on one
score big if foul do all these things to
release that pressure it just builds on
and you know LeBron will always be the
natural pressure release of course
Cleveland but you see right now in this
Philly sirs by the end that games how
fast that JJ reddick just tried to get
rid of that ball when you have it on the
one turnover a Ben Simmons do the same
thing yeah exactly but what that that's
that you're uncomfortable the whole game
they're up into you they have their body
on you they're taking away your space
they're making you do things you don't
want to do that pressure builds all the
time so can they put that much pressure
on all the other Cavaliers and put
enough pressure
LeBron that he's just not free willing
my goodness I mean the way he's playing
against Iran honestly I kid you not it's
like it's like it's like when you were a
really good pro player like you would go
to a college I went back to University
of Minnesota and just played in the
summer in a pickup game
you know you within the first two
minutes you're like oh man I didn't know
does it have some fun out here because
none of these kids are prepared to play
at the level that's going to challenge
you see it happen
that's what LeBron looks like they're
just like like like playing so relaxed
and he's just it's amazing to watch that
can the Celtics take some of that away
some of that comfort away from him
that's the interesting debate you sure
will Kevin look forward to tonight
really enjoy your call with Brian
Anderson have a good time tonight good
catch guys Kevin McHale the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience